it's rap time with another Scottish
person I am Gregor away from Gregor from
the Isle of Skye oh my gosh
super Scottish what would you like these
no rap about I'm gonna go for the most
Scottish things I can think of haggis
hey ya rabbee bones okay yeah whoo
nation's pride nation's pride okay
let's kick it I talked about the NP
nation's proud I just want to dive in
yeah down the slide I go so fast I hope
you follow this I go down the sheep's
esophagus into the stomach i plummet and
why do I find I found some mints maybe
mixed with some bacon round or other
cancer awful things it's awfully when
it's on burns night offered for you t
your address to the haggis stab it with
a stick put it in fast pull it out so
quick read all the poems that you learn
to school it's like Robbie Burns he's
the butter Scotland so cool like
Shakespeare but writes even more
confusedly I see it I'd be like oh like
Musa Lee it's not popular north of the
border alcoholism it's an awful disorder
so we world market endemic to places
people want to put the booze in they
faces they be like oh I need some booze
I put a dummy feast on my laryngeal
tubes that is the axon that I did don't
hurt me from the sky ages 30 that may be
the life expectancy goes there if you
have too much alcoholic things so take
care